too many americans admit to answering
after-hour work emails or messages seems
like a benign topic but it's really not
let's read seven in 10 people admit to
answering their work emails or messages
when they're off the clock
zimbra and one poll is that won't poll i
can't see partnered to survey two
thousand office employees about the pros
and cons of always being logged on they
found that seventy percent of people
actually appreciate receiving work
notifications at any hour of the day do
they though huh
do they
i don't buy it
employees may stay connected during
their free time to feel good about being
on top of their work
because they're hoping to move up within
the company and because they don't like
leaving things unfinished
but this doesn't mean the work takes
over respondents life
72 would still rate their work-life
balance as good or excellent i don't buy
that either
i don't buy it so here's the
conversation it's a multi-faceted
conversation life has changed it used to
be that
i remember when i was younger and my dad
went to work
he'd go to work
you know he had a i don't know he used
to get there really early actually so
leave the house say he was there from 7
00 am until 5 or 6 pm
drive home he had a long drive home he'd
come in the house
hey hi to the family there was no
contact with work at that point he had
dinner with all of us we sat down we had
a meal maybe he would have to tie up a
few loose ends with his pen and his
paper i mean old school think about it
this is the 1980s i'm talking about he'd
do a few little things
there was a lot of family time that was
spent there were a lot of distraction
free zones there was a lot of just
existing and being there was time to
wind down there was a wind down right
you wound up for the day you had your
day and then you wound down from the day
maybe you watched a little bit of the
news that night
you flicked it on to see if anything had
gone terribly wrong and you flicked it
back off that was your day
and you went to sleep
now what you have is you have the work
day goes all day now some people say
well that allows me for flexibility i
can answer whenever i want i can do
whatever i want i don't have to be
confined within that nine to five and
that flexibility makes them happy but
let me ask you something
ultimately how do you sleep at night do
you sleep well
do you i guarantee you a lot of you
don't sleep well because i struggled
with this we don't sleep well because we
have a ton of blue light a coming at us
all day long you heard about blue light
blockers that's real
computers cell phones we're buried in
the phone we're in the bed at night the
phone's in one hand the tv's on we're
like
there's always a sense of having
something to do and when does the wind
down happen
when do you get to actually
leave that workday behind take a deep
breath sit in your house and do nothing
turn on a movie sit with your family
have some bonding time that doesn't
involve being plugged in or are you
plugged in all day long and think about
does it make you anxious
does it make you feel like you work 24
hours a day i know you may not have to
be in the office from nine to five but
you're working 24 hours if you've got
that phone next to you
what is it doing to our psyche and is it
good
or bad for us is the work-life balance
maintained everybody says oh i work from
home so i have great work-life balance
and then i talk to them more and they're
like i don't know i always feel stressed
out i don't sleep very well i feel like
i'm just always eating too fast i i know
something's wrong and i can't figure it
out i work from home
i can't figure it out well because your
date your work day doesn't end
you you think you have work like balance
because you get to go to the gym in the
middle of the day and you get to answer
an email when you can and you get do you
though
or is work life and regular life now
just morphed into one
sticky slimy like can't separate them
thing
and all you know is that you never feel
like you get a break
that's how i felt until i made some
rules
put in some rules you'll never hear from
me before like 8 am or before a certain
time at night ever because the phone's
not around me so this is an interesting
question
do i think it's healthy this new dynamic
i personally don't
i personally don't i think there is
something to be said for a wind down and
i think having your mind racing it also
reminds me guys of the constant news
cycle
remember you used to just you turn on
the news you i always think of my dad
not that you're an antique dad if you're
listening but you're kind of an antique
i love you though but you know he'd read
the newspaper in the morning very
old-fashioned still does this goes he
wants a hard copy of the newspaper this
digital stuff's not for him he's like
i'm not doing it i'm not doing it i know
you're watching me private eyes so he's
like no
gets the newspaper gets his cup of
coffee reads the newspaper in the
morning
and does his work he still has some work
that he does on the side does that pen
and paper guys pen and paper old school
and then he has his day everything has a
place in his life
he's not doesn't have a constant
streaming of news coming in to his
computer or his twitter feed all day
long you know what that brings him peace
peace
he when he goes down to take a nap he's
not like me i go down to take a nap it's
like oh my god i have this dude let me
just answer this one oh i'm i'm trying
to nap and going through a grocery list
of everything i have to do and the
phone's right there so maybe let me just
wake up from this snap real quick and do
this let me just hold on a second maybe
i'm not by the time i go to take the nap
the the period of time that that's been
allotted to me which is basically the
time that my son is snapping is done
he goes in he's like read his newspaper
he's like i'm done with the news for the
day i'm gonna nap sleeps like a baby for
an hour and a half gets up
big stretch you know
and i'm like
twitching on the other side of the room
you know
so is this good
is this bad tyler you're young i call
tyler the youngin
he's young makes me feel like a dinosaur
we won't get into that
but you only my guess is no world where
this is all happening right so how do
you
do you feel like it's taxing when i
describe my dad's world is that
appealing to you or is that stressful no
it's it's uh it's absolutely more
stressful now like there are times where
i'll wake up and i'll spring out of bed
like i'm like late for something and
i'll go to jump in the shower it's two
in the morning and i feel like i'm late
for work like i'm late for something
like i gotta be going i gotta be rushing
this just reminds me of
of ariana huffington who i used to
really like watching her debate on bill
buck i used to be a big fan of ariana
and she she had serious burnout and she
was working one day and i guess she
collapsed at her desk and buried her
face into her glass desk and cut it all
up and everything and she started a
company and she's like i'm done no more
i can't do anymore started a company
called thrive
which helps to
help companies avoid the burnout crisis
of their employees and she's like listen
i started putting my phone to bed yeah
hour before i go down like and it's just
like you say you know you're always
watching television you've always got
the computer you've always got the phone
you're always getting text messages at
night like you're always running and
gunning
and it's
it's going to be interesting to see how
this generation
and millennials develop down the road
when they're done working and they're
retired right it's like what are they
going to be doing they're always going
to be doing something exactly they're
going to lose their minds and see i feel
really lucky because i have the
comparison like i grew up
watching in the 1980s
gosh
so long ago
simpler time
anyway i grew up then and i ha i was
able to see like oh okay
workday has a limit like what i just
described to you about my dad i had that
and now i see this
and i can see the benefits of both i can
see the dangers of this for sure
but like if you have a kid you know i
have this little boy and i'm like he
only knows
this and i don't want him to always see
me like that so i'm very conscious of
like he needs to see mommy like mommy
goes to work mommy comes home there
needs to be a break where i'm on him my
eyes are on him and i also this is very
hard and very challenging but you have
to get used to
as a parent
not doing this with your kids all the
time with the phone because they they
absorb that first of all they feel like
well what's that phone they get it the
sense well that phone must be really
important to mommy because it's sharing
my time with her
secondly they then learn that behavior
of that's how they're going to treat
people you know they're going to have a
phone that that's how they're going to
treat people who are actually in front
of them they model off of us so so often
and i remember
when i was in
a couple times in my life once when i
first started in tv burnout
i was doing hits i was doing free tv for
like a year and a half maybe longer i
have to look back and remember my dad
would know because he wrote it all down
a little journal that he still has
i don't remember how long it was but it
was a while and i was doing it and i was
like
i'm i'm like i need a minute it was like
oh can you show up here at 8 a.m oh can
you show up here at 10 p.m oh can you
there was like no rhyme or reason my
life just was lost
and i did it it was part of the grind
but i look back now and i'm like okay
you have to set some limits and then
when i had fox and friends i remember
over the weekend that time schedule was
horrific for me i was actually
considered not taking that job because i
was like
3am i don't know if my body is going to
work on that but it wound up being that
i was really working round the clock
some days
and i just made a decision
and i wrote that book
right around the time that i really made
a lot of changes but i just made a
decision
that it may not be 1985 but i was gonna
my life was going to look a little bit
like 1985 in some respects and that
phone was going to be out of my room at
night
and things were going to get shut off at
a certain time and
news wasn't going to be twitter was
going to be something i went to when i
like it was certain times a day i go i
check a few times a day but i'm not just
like on there all day i see people on
there that are tweeting
every minute
and i'm like every minute for 13 hours
what where do you eat
and yeah they do but they're eating
while they're doing that
that's a problem
that's a problem it's a real problem
it's creating mental health problems in
people it's creating anxiety depression
restlessness
um
sleeplessness
lots of things
from just always having your eyes on
something so i know this isn't you know
politically controversial but i do think
it is controversial because it tackles
some of this remote work that's being
glorified it tackles some of this
oh it's convenient it's good for you to
be plugged in all the time it tackles
some of what's happened with technology
in the last 10 years and what's really
not reversible you can't go back truly i
ask for the delorean because there's no
other way
there's no other way to get back to that
simpler time because you can't reverse
it's like you give an inch it's done
right you're not going to roll back
twitter there'll be something else that
pops up this is our new way of life the
phone
you know and just wait until there's no
you don't have to pause to pick up the
phone right wait till something like
neuralink comes out where you are
literally in a symbiotic relationship
there is there is no like it's it's you
you are it you know tyler if you think
i'm a dinosaur now
you wait you wait till this next round
of ai stuff comes out
you know where i'm gonna be i tell
people i'm gonna be
in an area of the country where there's
like no towers
cell towers there aren't going to be
anywhere i am there's going to be grass
there's going to be wells i have a
friend that has a water well
i'm like you have a water well he's like
yeah i go out need some water i'm like
what
it was so appealing to me that just
hearing about it may be euphoric that's
where i'm going to be
because this disconnect all of this by
the way
just as an added out all of this
is a disconnect to nature
it's a disconnect to each other
it's a disconnect to everything that
really grounds you as a human being we
talk about grounding into the actual
earth but what about what grounds you in
your relationships eye contact
connection
all of that stuff is getting lost and
it's all coming back to this idea that
you should be accessible to everyone
else 24 hours a day
there are times i'll write a message to
tyler at night i'll send him a message
for work and i'm like i hope he doesn't
answer because i hope he's not looking
at his phone
that's my second to do it because i'm
like i have a baby that's asleep but
truly people need every single person
needs peace and we one of our first
guests we're gonna have on here by the
way he's a great guest not gonna tell
you his name
can't put the goods out there i told you
but he's amazing he's going to cover um
a lot of toxicities and things that are
wrecking our mental health and our
physical health and a lot of it is going
to have to do
with this
as opposed to go for a walk
you know with this as opposed to go on a
date and actually like get those social
like like
get that feedback from someone because
you're paying attention to them
all of that stuff it's gonna be really
really fascinating if you like the short
clip you can catch another one here or
you can catch the full episode right
here
[Music]